>>> ACCORDING TO STUDIES, MANY
MEN SAY THEY HAVE NO CLOSE
FRIENDSHIPS.
AND THREE IN FOUR REPORT
RECEIVING ALL THEIR EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT FROM THEIR WIFE OR
GIRLFRIEND, OFTEN THE MOMENT
THEY COME HOME FROM WORK.
>> HI.
HOW ARE YOU?
I MISS YOU.
AM I BALDING?
"DUNE"?
>> OKAY, COOL.
HI, HONEY.
>> VIN DIESEL HAS A TWIN
BROTHER.
>> OH, HONEY.
WHEN I WALK IN THE DOOR, MY
HUSBAND SORT OF ROCKETS
INFORMATION AT ME FOR 25 MINUTES
STRAIGHT.
>> ON A FOOTBALL TEAM, THERE'S
11 PLAYERS, BUT WITH RUGBY,
THERE'S 15.
>> AND ALL THE WORDS COME OUT
FAST AND IN THE WRONG ORDER
BECAUSE HE HASN'T SPOKEN TO
ANYONE ELSE ABOUT THAT.
>> I NEED YOU TO GO OUT OF THE
HOUSE AND MAKE A FRIEND SO YOU
TALK TO OTHER PEOPLE ABOUT THIS
STUFF AND NOT JUST ME.
>> THAT'S INSANE.
WHERE WOULD I EVEN GO?
>> FINALLY, THERE'S A PLACE,
WITH MAN PARK.
IT'S LIKE A DOG PARK, BUT FOR
GUYS IN RELATIONSHIPS, SO THEY
CAN MAKE FRIENDS AND HAVE AN
OUTLET, BESIDES THEIR
GIRLFRIENDS AND WIVES.
>> RISE AND GRIND?
>> RISE AND GRIND.
>> RISE AND GRIND, BROTHER.
>> LOOK.
THEY'RE NETWORKING.
>> AWW, THEY'RE DOING SO GOOD.
>> WHICH ONE'S YOURS?
>> HE'S A LITTLE SHY.
>> AWWW.
GO ON.
GO SAY HI.
>> IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT
MASCULINITY MAKES INTIMACY SO
HARD.
>> MARVEL?
>> MARVEL.
MARVEL.
>> WE KNOW NOT ALL MEN GET
ALONG.
SO, THERE'S SEPARATE PARKS FOR
LARGE BREEDS.
>> PATS.
>> RAVENS.
>> AND SMALL BREEDS.
>> PATS.
>> RICK.
>> AND SMALL BREEDS.
>> MORTY.
>> RICK.
>> THERE'S ROOM FOR ALL THEIR
FAVORITE MALE BONDING
ACTIVITIES.
♪ CAUSE I'M
MR. BRIGHTSIDE ♪
>> AND AFTER THEY RUN AROUND AND
YELL, THEY CAN COOL DOWN WITH AN
IPA AND REALLY CONNECT.
>> REAL TALK, WHO'S THE
G.O.A.T.?
>> MICHAEL JORDAN?
>> TOM BRADY.
>> HOW ABOUT BEAU BURNHAM.
>> WILL YOU BE MY BEST MAN?
>> WE'RE NOT EVEN ENGAGED YET.
>> I'M SO GLAD HE HAS SOMEONE
ELSE TO TALK TO.
>> HEY.
>> HEY, DID YOU KNOW VIN DIESEL
HAS A TWIN BROTHER?
>> WHAT?
>> YEAH, AMAZING.
>> WHAT EXACTLY ARE THEY TALKING
ABOUT?
>> MEN ARE TAUGHT IT'S WEAK TO
RELY ON EACH OTHER.
SO I GUESS IN THAT WAY, AND
DON'T QUOTE ME ON THIS, IT'S
HARDER TO BE A MAN.
WAIT.
NO.
IS THIS FILMING?
DON'T SHOW MY FACE SAYING THAT.
>> MAN PARK.
LADIES GET IN FREE.
♪♪